it's great to be joined today by Luke
Vargas chief foreign correspondent for
talk media news joining us today from
Helsinki Finland after wrapping up a
week in the Baltic and attending of
course yesterday's Trump Putin I guess
we're calling it a meeting I don't I
don't really know what the right way to
sort of characterize it Finland Luke
what's it like what is the context of
Finland and sort of thinking about our
relationship with Russia well first let
me say I love Finland and I have found
the language to be the most difficult
thing about this country except for this
headline in the paper today
transcribe' booty yeah it's the only
thing in Finnish that I can understand
and I guess a fitting souvenir for this
trip this wasn't a summit was it we'll
get to that in a second it was there's
no agenda nope no actual deal to be
signed here Finland as a host has been
described over and over as a neutral
country which having talked to a lot of
experts here is something they sort of
reject this is a country in the European
Union that's adopted the euro and that
does drills with NATO but also has an
800 plus mile long border with Russia
and that's very important because it
sort of sets up a Finnish model for how
to deal with Russia appropriately that I
think president Trump in his press
conference yesterday decided not to
follow namely that you have to pursue a
working relationship with Russia when
you're Finland you can't afford to not
talk to not have cooperation between
border guards and militaries you you
need to understand your partner here but
that also means you can take decisions
you can pivot to the west or you can
decide not to and in this country they
have diverted to the west they but they
also call out Putin and yet they still
find a way to have a decent relationship
so a working relationship not
necessarily friendly relations and that
takes us to president Trump's argument
here that the reason that Russian
relations are being reset now of all
times is because these are nuclear
countries that together have 90 percent
of the nuclear or whatever Trump says
and that because of the importance of
nuclear weapon control and the
importance
fighting terrorism that that is a reason
these countries have to bury the past
forget all the things that separate them
and just focus on finding common ground
and those in Finland would say that's a
false choice and I do think the
proposition from Trump is insincere and
posits that nothing can be done on arms
control when there isn't a little when
there isn't just daylight no daylight
between the countries and that nothing
can happen on fighting terrorism
together as if law enforcement wouldn't
pass along a tip to another country if
there's a bonafide terror risk so I
think that's the false choice that has
bothered me coming out of this summit
yeah I mean when when it's hard to
forget the past when the past includes
already starting to meddle in the
midterms like as recently as yesterday
because that's maybe not far enough in
the past to be able to do that so the
press conference this was one of the
most bizarre and quite frankly
disgusting
performances I've ever seen by it by an
American president certainly during the
time I've been following politics and
you know I was doing the show during the
George W Bush administration so that
says quite a bit but on style what was
it like in the room because what was
transmitted through my multiple watches
of this thing and preparing for the show
it was a totally subservient Trump in
the context of his relationship to
Vladimir Putin did that come through in
the room or was it a different feel I
think it did because many of us many of
those go to myself who were in the room
our our experience with having traveled
with US presidents around the world and
seeing the traditional traditional
manner in which US presidents talked to
foreign heads of state and particularly
foreign heads of state from less than
democratic countries of which Russia
would certainly fit the mold and
typically what you see is the US
president making a calculation sort of a
deal with the foreign leader saying
they're probably never saying it
explicitly you know if you want to share
the stage with me then you're going to
need to take some questions Obama did
this with the Chinese with the Cubans
you know they try to squiggle out of the
questions Obama insists they answer
questions from the media and Trump today
or Trump yesterday really did the
opposite sort of it was an inversion of
that typical relationship he's shielding
for President Putin from certain
questions it's almost almost teeing him
up it's like for those of us in radio
he's like a perfect co-host right he he
like kind of senses the ad break is
coming and then like fixes his remarks
to like to give the host a a way to do
his live read it really felt like Trump
especially answering our in his prepared
remarks on the election sort of saying
yeah I brought it up I wanted to deal
with this one-on-one but Putin has a lot
to say about it he's got some really
interesting theories like there you go
buddy if I thought that style to be very
odd and there was no reciprocation and
that was very noteworthy that Putin even
though Trump was treating him with kid
gloves
still criticized the United States on
the Iran deal saying look the Iran deal
has made the world safer it's it's
working and actually criticizing the US
unemployment of anti-missile systems in
Eastern Europe which to me was maybe one
of those things Trump Putin slipped in
there to try and see this Trump bike
does he know the details here is this
something he might push back against of
course Trump if he caught it didn't have
anything to counter it with and I worry
actually that that was a little bit of
an indication as we talk about substance
of maybe what Trump may have requested
from our whether Putin requested from
Trump in their one-on-one I mean here we
get an idea of a possible Russian
complaint much like Kim jong-eun
complains about joint military drills
with South Korea
maybe Putin said hey you know you've got
anti-missile systems protecting the
Baltic and Poland pull those back from
Eastern Europe there are nuisance to us
so that's something I would watch and
again it was not a reciprocal
relationship between Trump and Putin
Putin got some barbs in against Trump so
transitioning sort of to substance but
it's still kind of related to style and
you can take this to the direction that
makes sense the moment where Trump
referred to Putin's idea of
collaborating with Russian officials on
the Moller investigation and calling it
an incredible idea which struck me as
maybe one of the the the most absurd
suggestions Trump has made during this
presidency so far what was the mood like
in the room where Trump called that an
incredible idea I will say and I I wish
I had more anecdotes about the spirit in
the room I mean I think the Russian
press corps hardly makes a peep no
matter what I guess if Putin laughed
they all laugh along with him you know
and I think the u.s. press corps to be
fair is so used to Trump's antics at
this point that we don't make it huge
like verbal much to do about certain
things so I can't really even
remember what the instant reaction was
to that but I think you know you're
starting to get at parts of this press
conference that I do think they sort of
maybe sound like one thing but then you
really consider what they mean and it
becomes absurd the other one comes to
mind for me is these two leaders
suggesting they're gonna have like
business representatives get together
and find out how to do more business
between the two countries
which is really against the spirit of
the whole sanctions regime which is you
know meant to really make Russia pay a
financial price for its misdeeds in
places like Ukraine and interview know
of poisonings in Europe in the United
Kingdom
I gotta match poisonings Luke alleged
poisonings with with genitals known only
to come from like two different places
on the planet yeah well I guess my other
big point on the the substance of the
conversation is that you know if it
weren't for these two very dogged
American reporters from Reuters and
Associated Press who just made sure
extra questions got asked in what was
supposed to be or otherwise would have
been a very short press conference let's
just look at the prepared statement from
Trump and consider this is what he
thought was acceptable at an absolute
minimum to have communicated let's say
for instance if the two questioners had
just you know talked about like space
the space force and you know something
else that's random like the World Cup
and we never got into the meet trump
would never have mentioned Ukraine and
he actually didn't the only West follows
follows up on that work to Putin he
never talked about Crimea he never
talked about the screep of poisoning he
never talked about Assad he ended up
actually praising Russia on its
relationship with Iran which it just
seems very odd and I will say you know
finally we don't know exactly what was
agreed to major agreements can be made
in two sentences behind closed doors and
may well have been made and so is one
thing to sort of say that we fully
understand Trump by reading the
transcript but that's never how Trump
works and I think we should be afraid
about maybe the deals that were made
behind the scenes that we may never know
about that is absolutely what I've been
thinking about before you went to
Finland you also were in Latvia and
Estonia you visited NATO troops
politicians I mean actually I'm actually
going to be in Estonia in a few months
as part of a project that I'm
we're interested in what that's like but
in the context of the Trump Putin
bromance we could call it or maybe the
the cuckoldry that is going on is this
something that should be concerning it
for those allies in the region well
nothing happened yesterday from the
people I've talked to in in the Baltic
region that amounted to let's say a
humiliating concession that truly
undermined them you know we did not see
president Trump for instance saying he
was going to veto further expansion of
NATO which is one thing Russia wants he
nor did the u.s. or president Trump
agreed to some sort of forced posture
change for the US military agreed to
suspend joint military drills in the
Baltic or really even critique NATO he
reserved that for earlier in the week
and yet the Baltic probably remains the
most vulnerable to Trump's temperament
as it pertains to his views on NATO this
is a region that has now a deterrence in
the form of these forward the battle
groups of which the US has one in Poland
that at oversees which according to most
people I've talked to him which I would
in his first hand do seem to be acting
as a very strong deterrent against some
sort of Russian aggression there those
kind of vulnerabilities could come right
back into play if Trump let's say
carries through on a threat as he
apparently made in Brussels to perhaps
you know sort of go it alone outside of
NATO if those countries don't meet these
exceedingly difficult to reach spending
targets by year's end which won't happen
I will also say the country that
probably if we take the Baltic out of it
that is most concerned about what
happened yesterday will be Ukraine which
got no support no verbal support from
President Trump we don't even know if it
was brought up in their meeting and I
will say in fact the only time Ukraine
is mentioned yesterday they are
criticized by Putin and Trump doesn't
stand up for them Putin says look it's
actually Ukraine which isn't living up
to the Minsk agreement and there are
some things they're not doing they're
not making public services let's say
very accessible for certain people in
the dome boss in eastern Ukraine and
then he had Putin chides Trump saying
you need to put pressure on Ukraine to
live up to their commitments that is so
lopsided it's got to be driving policy
makers in Ukraine Matt last thing Luke
in the limited time we have my part of
highlights from this Europe trip for
Trump are
shows up suggests the idea of maybe
leaving NATO in two different degrees of
directness single-handedly torpedoes a
significant portion of our relationship
with Germany which has been an ally of
the United States for a long time and
then indicates that he is totally
subservient to Vladimir Putin am I
missing any of the highlights like is
that are those the lasting implications
of this trip I I think you're getting at
them what I how I would sum it up is
that the US and Russia have long had
very different views about you know
whether they want to be in a
neighborhood of similar Nations or
whether they want to go it alone and try
and pursue less a bilateral
relationships with other countries where
they have more influence and I think
what we've seen over the past week is
convergence there that now both the US
and Russia have designs to divide and
conquer or divide and overpower Europe
Trump wants to do this economically he
finds the European Union to be a
nuisance he would rather make individual
bilateral trade deals not just with them
but with everyone around the world
instead of working through multilateral
frameworks Putin wants to do this
through foreign policy much like the
pipeline we may have you may have talked
about last week with Angela Merkel which
sort of cuts out the Baltic allows
Russia to have more one on one minute or
the threats that they can make to
different countries to cut off their
energy supply Trump Putin sees things
the same way from may not know this is
exactly what he's doing but and the
leaders are probably doing this for
different reasons but it's certainly
happening and finally I would say
partisanship has been injected into
foreign policy in a major way by
President Trump and he admitted himself
sort of saying the reason I had this
meeting the reason I'm making relations
better with Putin right now is because
Democrats said I shouldn't I forget his
exact phrasing but something along the
lines of I can't set foreign policy
based on Democrats who want nothing but
obstructionism he can take that tack but
it has huge ripple effects for the
future diplomacy of the United States
because it makes not just for
Republicans but for Democrats any future
successes in the diplomatic realm more
difficult to actually implement because
then immediately as you come you know
back home from abroad even a good deal
that's been signed is going to be seen
as a win for President Trump or a win
for a future Democrat instead of a win
for
America and its foreign policy and I
think that change and the the one about
the US and Russia starting to both agree
I'm wanting to divide split up Europe
and deal with countries so they have
maximum you know advantage one-on-one
those are big takeaways that truly shift
the way America acts in the world follow
Luke on Twitter at the courier Luke
Vargas is the chief foreign
correspondent for talk media news
joining us today from Helsinki Finland
in a makeshift sauna here in a makeshift
of incredibly hot room so we're gonna
end the interview so Luke can towel off
Luke thank you as always thank you David
bye-bye